hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to uh Zen blade the game
where you slice up fruit with a sward at
least that's what I think it is there's
only stuff right in front that is sward
and fruit and I'm gonna slice oh look at
that oh that's so what uh dot ha oh
it is fruit ninja oh yeah jeez my face
ha
swaps wha oops up pink hair look oh
ah this literally is just fruit ninja
but it's so cool not that ya got that
well oh hey do i ha ha ha ha ha oh
this is so cool and I need to put this
other one devoir
hey Georgia Georgia uh uh ah ha ha ah ah
bleh Oh slay slay slay slay slay slay
slay slay slay slay OH
stay away sly yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes I love this is so cool well
no oh well that sounds like bad
oh that's cool where'd my other one go
who cares I care if I'm gonna step on it
where to go where to go we're gonna go
ask you where to go
oh boy well this ain't any kind of good
where to go I could take my headset
off then be smart oh it's over there
okay we're good we're fine okay so I'm
gonna put the strap on because it's
gonna end badly for me this is one of
those games it's gonna get me out of
breath oh I didn't mean that one
time trial I don't want that sounds like
a lot of bitchest nish yeah I'm already
an expert you can you can give me more
advanced ones
oh okay uh you thought you knew me
ah you killed my father I'm here to kill
you back Oh
haw-haw doink
OOP huh ha hi oops
whoa ha yes it's so cool ha ha ha yes
yeah Oh God
it was I mean I know it's just
fruit ninja but ha ha ha
seeing it in VR like this is kind of
nuts whoa that hit me in the face hit me
in the dick maybe whoa oh
whoa this is getting nuts ha ha ha
oops ha ha ha oh oh well blah blah blah
sure sure trip swap swap
sure wash 112 truck play play play play
play play play slay slay slay slay slay
light light
yeah I did bad oh man I hit six home son
of a that ain't good I got to
number 1898 that's probably good
probably you oh whoa son of a ah
huh it'd be bugged out on me that wasn't
my fault
okay I'm ready for you ha what the
what the fat with the sack Oh phew
huh I can do this I know I can do this I
can do this
I let my inner peace go through me it's
like the training I hadn't Himalayan
mountain to the child I had to use I had
to carve my own sword I'm a judge my
baby teeth and I used that as a club
because I was too stupid actually you
like a sword I thought I thought it we
will ship that were just hitting things
yeah I'm about to unleash my Jitsu jutsu
jitna I'm about to learn leech my van up
your tiny watermelon you don't
deserve that I would explode you with
rubber bands oh did it get it
I'll come on we'll just fall already why
did I try to catch that I really did I
really tried to catch that that was
weird
wah wah well that's tiny oh it's tiny
whoa I didn't even see it what's up you
go put tiny ones Rene aah Leigh if you
hit it with even slightly the flat of
your blade it'll just knock it up
against whoa what Wow oh
whoa I didn't see it god damn it I
didn't see it hundred
twenty-seven 252 I can do better than
that I know I can do better than that I
know I'm better than that I'm not better
than I don't ever lose matter threated
lawyer this is probably one of the
coolest via uses of VR that I've seen
because it implements pretty much
everything that I like about VR which is
the immersion one the free roaming
movement that I have in the other ones
and three the hand-eye coordination that
needs to be one-to-one to be true and
this offers all of that like 100% it
offers everything that I like out of the
experience and it also is a really cool
test of skill like obviously it's not
real test the skills that were really
this much fruit like I'm pretty sure the
world hunger organization with them so
words to say to me because of all the
waste for my training but I want to be a
Super Saiyan so badly if I'm gonna get a
new power level I need to slice this
goddamn fruit for Goku cuz he eats a lot
yeah because that is what like look I
mean just look I'll you oh off
oh I don't so god and then I lose there
at the end there because
yo good thing I wore
comfortable clothes for this because
otherwise I'd be sweating out my jeans
and stinking up my whole room not that
my room doesn't stank already it's a
mixture of dog and man funk which comes
from me not chica she's a lady but she
stinks huh cool
sois that was almost bad who are poor
whoa oh that was hard that was
really hard better than hitting a bomb
though I'll take that one huh whoa okay
okay so here's the earth round whoa
oh god that was close
whoo whoa whoo oh whoa I
didn't hit that bomb goddamnit 165 I
knew I could have done better I didn't
hit that puck jerk I must take my
aggression out on more fruit must kill
more fruit lost revenge family who was
murdered by fruit wha-wha-wha
wha-wha-wha
oh boy
it's my weakest direction that's just a
joke I don't have a weak direction all
my directions go in one oh no time for
jokes okay boy okay what oh
man nineteen is that good I don't know I
don't know how long I've been playing
guys I don't even know if something went
wrong with the with the recording I
think I've been going about two hours
but I'm not under present certain
haven't been talking this entire time
I've been unbelievably focused on just
perfecting my holding style but also
keeping it a bit away from my body
because there were some tracking bugs I
mean mostly it was just me missing like
I will readily admit that was that was a
problem but there are some tracking bugs
so if like the position gets offset like
by an inch then there's going to be
obviously a little problem it's going to
skirt to the side and maybe knock it
around so and also a consistency of
slice in terms of speed is necessary
like you got to get it like the speed
can't be too fast or else there's you're
going to get another tracking bug where
the the vibe can't keep position of your
hands and then it'll jet around because
it is like that sorry
concentrating anyway I'm just trying to
get the hiscore yes this is taking this
much effort God oh my arm is really
tired guys
hoo-boy oh my god Oh aah
muscles burning I'm out of shape huh
wash it keep it up okay okay
hook oh oh how the pain is
rather immense jolly bags holy
like a noose good god oh my god oh
me ah ah ow oh my god ah okay
I broke 200 Oh am i oh my god I just I
also realized recently that I got fourth
on the daily leaderboard and then I'm
20th overall man oh man
I've been playing this a long time a
long time holy oh wow I got to take
this off holy crap oh man let me check
how long I've been off I that doesn't
say that was who an adventurer I don't
even know what time it is I feel like I
I woke up in a different universe holy
I've been playing that for two and
a half hours Wow so that is really fun I
did pretty good and then I got obsessed
with victory so much that I kept playing
and my arm and shoulder just started
getting more and more tired and then it
started hurting really bad on that last
one but I broke 200 which is a good
place to stop on so thank you everybody
so much for watching I'm probably gonna
play this on my own if you want to see
another video of it I'm gonna try for
the number one or at least the top ten
on the leaderboard so thank you
everybody show it for watching and let
me know what other VR games you want me
to play in the future and thanks again
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
I was impressive probably not